this is a production of cornell
university
so so my um my talk today is about the
native hawaiian beginning farmer program
um
and i would like to acknowledge my two
colleagues alton arakaki and jennifer
hawkins
um alton and i have worked on molokai
together for about 28 years
uh well actually more than that 38 years
uh he just retired two years ago
he's been working with the native
hawaiian community before i started this
job so that was really
a positive for us being able to have
almost 60 years of experience working 70
years experience working with the
hawaiian community
um jennifer hawkins
is from arkansas was in extension for 15
years
came over to molokai and added the
southern drawl to our program
uh fit in very well uh communicates very
well with the native hawaiian community
and
she plays a very important role in
evaluation
and even counseling of our farmers okay
next
so this is um at my home state i grew up
tarot and bananas and all kinds of stuff
um my wife is a fifth generation
hawaiian homesteader
their families moved here when the land
was set aside
back in the 1920s um this was part of
the hawaiian homes act
when captain cook so-called discovered
hawaii there are probably about a half a
million hawaiians
by 1870 there are only 70 000 hawaiians
left
and this was from all the introduced
diseases um
influenza measles and especially
smallpox
so a program was developed uh we had a
prince
prince kuhio who was in congress
and was able to set aside a program to
repatriate
the native hawaiians and 200 000 acres
was set aside
um for this purpose next
here are my two colleagues outstanding
in their field we have a
demonstration farm on the island uh of
which we have total control over the
facility we have research trials
uh we conduct either individually or as
a team and also
bringing in researchers from the other
islands to assist us in this endeavor
next
so the goal was to create 22 new farmers
um
if achieved we would double the number
of farmers in hollywood
the main objective was to do hands-on
and this is a debate we had through the
entire program
i'm really into classroom training
theory
science and my my colleagues saying
learn by doing they got to get out in
the field
i said well you can do learn by doing
but
if they don't have the science they
can't diagnose the problems
and to me that was a real important
thing so i spent a lot of time
writing up curriculum making sure that
they can understand that it's
at a level that they can comprehend the
second thing we're looking at
was um hoping that they all
don't all go out there and buy forty
thousand dollar tractors
so we tried to set up a rental program
this is still going on we have some
equipment we're trying to expand on it
um and then to teach them how to use
different equipment we have a lot of
equipment at the station
that we're able to move uh to the land
and i can explain the program a little
bit more in this next slide
okay so the justification for the
project we have over 7
800 acres of flat agriculture land in
this area
um and the hawaiians have two-thirds
prior rights to the water
uh it's something that i spent a lot of
time on fighting for our water rights
less than five percent of the land is in
agriculture production and
knowledge in agriculture has been
identified as a major impediment to
increased production
but like anything else in agriculture
the land is only one piece of the puzzle
you have
water you have the knowledge you have
markets
um you have the business aspects and you
need to be able to teach them all of
this
next
and the farm population is aging like
anywhere else
okay this is holy hole nice flat land
very windy you can actually tell the
farmers because they always lean forward
when they walk
um access to land under control of their
immediate family
many of them have 35-acre lots um
all of these are prerequisites we really
didn't want to deal with the
infrastructure issues
they had land they had water um
and they needed to have a half acre
prepared uh ready to
plant this meant not a whole lot of
trees on it
and we made it real stringent where you
had to have less than two years
experience we didn't want to have
experienced farmers
in there kind of dominating the
conversation
so we uh we really made it stringent
next
so some of the demographics the island
is uh 260 square miles
10 by 38 population of about
8 000 people on a good day a lot of
people travel between the islands
even on boats sometimes but not too much
right now
highest unemployment cost of living i
saw some figures recently
of 85 higher the state of hawaii 85
higher than the national average we must
be like
over a hundred percent higher uh very
interesting ethnicity on this island
um 65 hawaiian 25 filipino
uh from the pineapple industry that used
to be here
uh the pineapple closed one plantation
closed in 1976
the second in about 1982 uh 17 000 acres
of
pineapple um 60 of the workforce was out
of a job
throughout our job we have a very small
service and tourism industry
no fast foods no building over two
stories high and the major employment is
government and agriculture
it's interesting because this was one of
the first
places where corn production took place
in the 60s
where we had a winter winter plantings
so small um farms in the midwest
uh family farms mostly would come over
here plant in around
august come over and pollinate
around christmas time which was really
great for them as
they dealt with four foot of snow back
in nebraska and illinois
um and so the
one of the main industries in hawaii is
still um gmo corn
monsanto and there's a couple of new
ones one
the chinese bought out dao and i think
there's another one
so we have one of them on uh molokai
beer well formerly monsanto
beer we're part of maui county
so decisions are made there however we
have a strong community
bottom-up decision making and as i
mentioned earlier rural no buildings
over
two stories no fast foods or chain
stores
um we have some signs out in front of
this uh restaurant slow food
everyone knows everyone uh strong
hawaiian identity and activism we're
like the bellwether island for activism
in the state
uh and we have the largest concentration
of ancient hawaiian fish ponds probably
the largest one is about 500 acres
and this island anciently was known as
aina mona or the fat land
next
so our participant participants range in
age from
age from about the mid 20s to the early
50s a lot of small families like this
one
next and for uh some of them
generational their parents were always
also farming and they were also farming
and this is one
one example next
so the strategy was classroom
but at the same time a lot of
demonstration
a lot of hands-on um mentoring by us
all of us have background in agriculture
so we mentored individuals
we consoled this was an important part
of the program we were involved with
our social workers early in a program
because we didn't want to have to deal
with
family issues such as drugs or abuse and
those kind of things so we kind of
screened them
uh in that way to make sure that um
nothing was holding them back from
being successful in farming uh the
counseling was really interesting
we had um jennifer hawkins did a lot of
the counseling in the office
our office is right next to the post
office
right in the hawaiian hawaiian homes
area and this is a
highest traffic area because everybody
picks up their mail from the post office
and this was by design um actually
design the office and
secure the land and secure the money to
build our office right next to the post
office
so this is one of our um one of our
farmers
he is now our farm to school extension
agent on the island
works in the schools um trying to move
some of
our farm um our food farm food
into the stools into schools and also
teaching uh
students on a farm okay next
so the carrot it was real interesting
because we really wanted to get them
into the business
aspects and they were keen and hawing
said you have to do a production mat
uh we don't need a production map i said
you have to do a production map
so they're all ground and stuff and i
said okay here's the deal
you do your production map and we will
bankroll your half-acre demonstration
project
so you know buy all the supplies the
fertilizer
the drip irrigation all our areas all um
irrigated
it's a very dry area maybe 40 to 60
inches of rain
except in the last month we probably had
over 40 to 60 inches of rain
uh some days we had actually had two
inches in r
so i don't know if you folks heard about
the big storms over here but it's just
radical yesterday we had 50 mile an hour
winds
in the last month we'd have three
episodes of 50 mile an hour winds
um so it was interesting they all jumped
through the hoop
to get that funding for their half acre
project
in addition we cleared another half acre
for them after they completed the
program
next so the whole idea was for them to
do
incremental plantings um
you know a little each each month or
each week uh we had
markets set up for them in the stores uh
some of them were growing papayas and we
had them marketing to
whole foods
so where do they learn um
in the back of a truck next
next okay this is probably getting stuck
a little bit
um in the field we have a lot of fuel
workshops what we do is um
we'll visit each other's farms and they
would they would kind of pick up on each
other's
work that they're doing a lot of
different crops a lot of
walking in in the office and uh that was
really important we really wanted to
deal with them
in the office some of them would get
very dependent on us
you know come come in and ask questions
and i would just look at them and not
say anything
and they would realize that okay we had
that in the class i said yes we had that
in the class
read your notes so you don't want to
create dependence you want to create
independence and you want to create
interdependence
on the hawaiian community is really
strong in interdependence
some of these individuals have lived
next to each other
for five generations which is really
unique in hawaii
next
so this teachable moment and extension
is really important you want to have
that moment
they'll come to you and they'll mention
something and boom okay i got to teach
them this right now
and that i think that was really
important to have that kind of
relationship with them
um they would learn how to run the
tractor and line their fields
in fact we showed this uh presentation
to uh
the dean in honolulu and she goes whose
tractor is that
oh that's our tractor what are they
doing running these tractors
liability that's the university was
freaking out on a liability but
we had to work um out of the box and
look at what would work to teach them
next so field diagnostics was really
important for them to know
um how to identify diseases viruses
and things of this nature should so i
would go out in the field they were
growing different crops on different
farms and
we could show them all the different
diseases and stuff
next uh teaching them
ceiling mixes bent how to make benches
for their greenhouses
this is um down at the demonstration
farm we have uh 28 acres there
we're dealing with a deer problem right
now the last thing i heard we had 350
deer in the
in the farm uh so i think a lot of
shooting is going on over there right
now
next um teaching them incremental
plannings
this is something more conventional but
in hawaii this can be a problem at times
because if you have an
insect or a disease problem it just goes
right down the field
but we just wanted to teach them the
importance of being consistent
next
identifying virus is really important um
and i still reflect on a time when uh
rosaria providenti and
dennis gonzalez came to um molokai i
think they're on their way back from
china um
looking for um some resistant
i think i think it was zucchini yellows
resistant um
cucumbers and stuff so he came to
molokai and he was looking at some
peppers and i said this is a virus he
said no that is not a virus i said this
is a virus and at the end of the day he
finally
admitted that was a virus so viruses can
be real
a problem in hawaii especially in our
area which really dry
we don't deal with a lot of diseases per
se but we deal with a lot of viruses
next
um they needed to learn all the little
things about
repairing things repairing their main
line right here we're paying a two-inch
main line so they needed to learn every
aspect of farming
next uh they installed all their own
drip irrigation
we helped him with the design we had an
excel program
developed by um one of our one of our
team
so they could um put their together how
big their field was going to be and they
could design their drip irrigation
next this was class one
um we had a lot of fun working with
these guys
um what was interesting about the cohort
is they became
lifelong uh friends they got real close
they would share
one thing interesting about the online
community um especially this team is
that
they're willing to share what they're
doing there's no secrets
um and this is not every man for himself
they're willing to help um each other
next
now this is um another one of our
farmers john freeman he was doing papaya
and
all kinds of different crops and um very
innovative
his uh uncle had a sweet potato farm so
he kind of understood the
basics of growing on green crops and he
was doing
organic papaya and doing a really good
job at it
i think there's one more slide on this
picture
so class one we had
14 participated um we had a high
percentage of female
in fact we had at least nine uh
couples in the group which i thought
would work really well we really were
pushing for family type um
programs because that way you can make
the um
education more generational 42
started farming we had all kinds of
different crops
um we had butternut squash uh john here
grew butternut squash during the winter
months after the fresh stuff start uh
stopped coming to hawaii
mentoring of class two by class one a
very important aspect of the program
next okay that's so john
everybody kind of had a different quote
for us
uh man john used to mention sometimes i
would go on his farm i said you got a
problem here you know you got these
viruses you're not controlling them
you got to cull out the plants and and
he usually took it in in stride you know
he realized that
i wasn't there to hurt him i'm trying to
help him so
he talked about that um even when he
started farming full-time
he said well everybody's telling me i
should plan a half acre of papaya i said
do not
plant a half acre of papaya start at a
quarter and work your way up
so what does he do he plants a half acre
and every time i see him and he's
another picture of him
you could go on that one um every time i
saw him he was like running around with
a chicken without
like a chicken without a head and i told
him i told you
you know now you you got the farm
controlling you you're not controlling
the farm
so next year he shifted back to um
quarter acre and every time i saw him
everything was going great
so i think it's this this idea of how
much they can handle is really important
next
okay so he had organic papaya we have a
bunch of
homesteaders growing organic papaya
we're the only ones that can grow
organic
because we don't have the papaya ring
spot on our island
and it's rampant on the other island so
the other islands have to grow the
genetically modified papaya
next
some farmers were trying all kinds of
stuff this is michael buchanan he was um
every time he taught a different crop he
wanted to grow that crop and i said
you gotta focus so he was doing
strawberries he was doing uh
bulb onions and he also was doing
aquaponics
okay next
uh we had some really interesting
farmers this is one of them
um carl caporita she is um half filipino
half hawaiian
and she had all these herbs especially
the filipino ones
none of which i saw i've seen before she
goes i got all these herbs i got to grow
herbs
right on you know and she was learning
to farm for the first time so it was a
real challenge but
what she did was she got a lot of family
and friends involved in her farm
so some of the class two we had 16
participated 37
female 50 completed their production map
i think we got some more data for this
page 50
started farming and they were being
mentored by the agents
as well as the class one um
so carl was one of them that every time
she wanted
a question answered she would come to
the office and i would just look at her
i wouldn't say anything he goes
oh okay it's in the papers i said yeah
it's in the paper
uh you again you don't want them to be
um
dependent on you you want to really push
their independence and their
interdependence
next
we had one farmer um he's his wife is
hawaiian and he's samoan
and his wife would call up every
year every year i want my husband's
husband to be in the program
and this is another hawaiian homes
community about seven miles away
but i didn't want to uh have the
tractors run on the highway so i
kept on holding back she finally just
kept on bugging me and allowed them to
um
to be in the program and he was a really
good farmer um
he made value-added products with this
tarot
something called laula which is a
delicacy in hawaii it's a
pork wrapped with taro leaves and he was
actually
mailing it to the mainland to college
students on the mainland
this guy was trying all kinds of stuff
you know he was really successful
okay next
and um this tarot this is the same farm
this tower
grew about eight foot eight feet tall um
and we by by growing in these different
areas we really found out what can grow
and we couldn't assume his neighbor was
growing
um head cabbage and this is at um
sea level and i said this cabbage is not
going to grow here it's too hot
and the drop we grew some old french
varieties and they grew really well
next
next one
okay so they learned a lot of different
techniques um
this was planting the herbs the filipino
herbs
teaching them how to use different uh
types of equipment
uh they involved their cousins and
friends uh which was really good in
setting up
a lot of the farm and then this
multiplier effect of learning
so you had all these um individuals some
of whom
actually went to community college after
this experience
next
um cover crops is really important um
really pushing them to understand the
different cover crops
we have a big num uh root not nematode
problem um
on molokai so you need it to do crop
rotation
this is sunhem the other one we use is
um sorghum sudan
there's only a few crops that have real
strong uh tolerance to
that nematode especially our strain of
melody going
melody guy giovannica okay next
uh we had some farmers doing organic
watermelon they're real interesting
because uh
on oahu they make this organic
fertilizer
it's from all the spoiled meats from the
big boxes such as sam's place and costco
as well as the fish market we have a lot
of fish coming in from the pacific
so these guys would buy all this
material
probably get given to them they would
compress it and
pull out the oils and use their the oils
to run their equipment
and they would dry and dehydrate steam
and dehydrate this material
and we would buy it and bring it to the
island in um one ton
sacks so this guy i said we should try
injecting it through the line so what we
did was he mixed up molasses
and worm castings and it worked
and so the researchers at uh said no way
i said come check it out
so they came over and what was
interesting about that first they
couldn't believe it but
second they were able to refine the
process um
and we didn't need to use the molasses
and part you know bubbling up of the
process we used
uh worm castings and we're able to
bubble it up overnight
it'll break it down we just have to use
really good filters so
we didn't get any of this material in
the drip line
next
and this is some of the watermelon you
can sell it on the island for 50 cents a
pound you made a whole lot of money off
for this one
next
uh we had broccoli most of the crop uh
was for
molokai some of it went off island
some uh such as taro went to maui
okay next
uh and we decided to run this pollinator
um education program um molokai at one
time was the big capital of the honey
capital of the world back in the 1930s
we had a lot of honey production here um
and we lost the market uh in the 19
late 1930s because our market was
germany and the war started
um it's interesting because usda didn't
want us to do bees they didn't
feel that bees were a crop but i think
it was really important in terms of
pollination of our cucurbits and other
crops
um we had 10 uh two rounds 10
participants each
20 total half of them came out of the
beginning farmer program and half of our
new homesteaders
excellent excellent program um we have a
lot of different bees in the different
areas
um and they all learn how to
collect bees from the wild and it's
interesting because some of the bees are
really wild and some of them are real
docile
and so one day they were going out to
the west end to
collect the hive and i knew it was a
wild one so i didn't show up
and they all got stung i bumped into
them at the store later in the days
oh we all got stung they just were
attacking us and i said yeah i kind of
expected that one
but it was this giant ball of a hive
next
and this is important especially since
uh although we don't have a raw mite
on this island we do have the small
beehive beetle
so it's a whole new way of raising bees
now you need to check them all the time
you need to make sure they got enough
food you may need to plant pollinators
in the
nectar sources in the field so they
learn all of this and they did a lot of
this stuff
next
so this is using buckwheat to attract
the bees
to the field uh we even figured out the
timing on how
soon to plant it before uh the crop
would be planted
next
and this is a watermelon feel in um this
is um
my homestead uh so you
a lot of times the bees are not in the
area you want to be able to
get them in the area before the
pollinating is needed
um and this field did really well like
no misshaped fruits misshapen fruits
okay one of our beginning farmers
started making honey this is the
mesquite honey considered some of the
best in the world
uh he won two awards statewide awards
one was the best honey in the year one
and the second he won
um people's choice award for the second
year hawaii natural honey
competition he has another honey made
from mangrove that is gold in color
beautiful next
so survey of communication methods um
cell phone was really important in
communicating with us they were always
calling us up when you had a problem
60 news email some of them use no email
which was a real problem for us
um 60 stopped by the office which was
positive we really wanted this to happen
and
make this a habit next
so survey of learning methods 70
learn best through fuel activities and
this is
real common for the native um hawaiian
community
they want to touch they want to feel
that's that's real important part of the
culture
and 90 of the participants rated the
program excellent
next
so lesson learned understanding the
clientele their needs and learning level
was really important in developing the
program
um steady feedback always like
how was that class did you learn a lot
how should we change it
um do you need a one more of that class
so and the cohorts worked really well
and created lasting bonds
it was really funny because in hawaii in
hawaiian culture there's
really important events one is a
one-year-old party for the baby because
in the past i guess a lot of them didn't
make one year
so one-year-old party graduation more
common more
now i guess graduation marriage and
death
so one of them was having a a graduation
party she goes oh i'm having a
graduation party and
i'm trying to figure out what i'm going
to do and that was it
the members of the class one gave them a
pig the other one gave him the tarot
leaves
somebody made them poi and she had
almost all the
ingredients for her party and these
parties on the island i mean pretty much
the whole island comes to some of these
parties
um so that strong
interdependence ethic we were able to
capitalize on that
that was really important um the
extension approach of here she
do is very important this whole
extension um
methods are critical and this job was
beyond the regular duties of extension
definitely i mean we're stepping into
new areas we're not supposed to do
constantly we're not counselors
um we're mentors we're mentors in a
certain way but
we went a little beyond that and really
sitting down with them and helping them
to understand
what they're doing and why they're doing
it next
okay so post grant activities all right
i've been doing a
monthly newsletter changed to quarterly
up to about
i think about a year and a half ago i
ran out of gas
there's too much stuff going on um i'll
probably do a few more before i retire
at the end of this year
next um
we created a new farmer's cooperative um
it's still a work in progress
organizations are really a challenge in
a way
on molokai but they um this
this ethic of interdependence works
right into this
um we have some equipment we're trying
to expand the cooperative right now
we have partnerships with a lot of
non-profits to assist us in the effort
of grant writing and training
uh we um secured a 40 000
usda business grant um
we're still trying to work on this
because we're bringing a lot of the
green waste
out of the landfill and then composting
it
this has been a work in progress a lot
of the farmers were actually clearing
land and making biochar which worked out
really nice
and we received other grants to help us
on this effort we're still working with
these groups
um it's kind of expanded we've gone into
gardening
doing covet a lot of requests for um
for gardening we also have a resource
library
in the office but i think now with
internet we may not need that
but i think some of them are still old
style they still want to read a book
um and we have ongoing one-on-one
technical assistance for this group
as well as everybody else on the island
next
so collaborator is really important in
the rural community
we have a supply cooperative actually
started by hawaiian homesteaders back in
the 1970s
brings in most of the supplies they need
very important
we have a molokai community college farm
which we actually created
with maui community college and it's a
joint facility
which we also run our demonstration farm
the bee project um
uhb project for manoa provided a lot of
technical support
we had a producer on the island wanting
to teach others to do it
we also had had access to homesteaders
association tractor service
again trying to stay away from buying
tractors um
trying to maximize the use of equipment
in the community
we have a usda plant material centers
right on the edge of the hawaiian
homelands
that were able to work with learning how
to use
cover crops and other and native plants
as pollinators
molokai community services center we run
grants through them
um usd natural resource conservation
service programs
we had them hook up to the programs such
as cost sharing for
wind breaks and irrigation systems we
also had them um hook up with a
farm service agency which i think we
didn't list over here
department of hawaiian homelands funded
a position which is my old position
um and we had manoa based faculty
assisting in the effort
kohala center is another grant writing
agency
and we also has had assistance from the
county of maui office of economic
development
of this center on molokai is one of the
centers we actually developed as well
with the county of maui
business assistance center next
so this is getting to the last slide we
try to
let the community know what's going on i
have access to the local newspaper i
used to write articles almost every week
at times kind of slowed down right now
and
everybody's grumbling about grumbling at
me telling me where's the articles where
are the articles
um usually if there's something going on
that's really
a problem um i'll write an article if i
if i walk around a store and three
people ask about the same thing
um that's usually an indication that i
have to write an article
next so the fruits
so we had people making all kinds of
stuff we had
watermelon and papayas we had aquaponics
taro
um
next
so we had a lot of new ground being open
uh we had
heavy equipment to come in and open up
these new fields
next
um a lot of hands-on creating the next
generation of farmers
next
and that is the end of my presentation i
didn't even time it it was only
30 minutes
any questions comments
it's getting uh unmuted enough the
screenshot glenn thank you
so much for a fantastic
presentation and also uh for doing it
as a a dawn presentation
uh from hawaii uh you're the long
many times zones away uh i'm sorry
uh you couldn't see me cracking up at
your jokes but
uh they'll be again soon um so i have a
bunch of things i could ask
but i think if we can uh open it up for
i think the questions in the chat if if
you
just kind of get in line there and so
i'll read them but if you want
if anybody wants to um kind of
ask in person or your voice just kind of
interrupt me and go
so marvin prince asked with the about
the the history of
land use in the sites that are being
opened for agriculture well
what were they before okay a lot of them
our
area was in pineapple there are 17 000
acres
in pineapple um on
other other islands sugar took up
a lot of the space so the lands are open
from sugar
sugar the last sugar plantation closed i
think about three years ago
on maui that was
i can't remember the monoland i want to
say 14 000 but i think it's more than
that
so every island had large production
um and somebody made up uh yeah the
pineapple was really hard on the soil
and that's why i think when we came to
some of these areas
like in holy war you had to really build
it up
uh you may have had herbicides
we were able to overcome the herbicide
problems with
nitrogen just getting the microbes
working in the soil
adjusting the ph bringing it back from
the low levels of like
six point oh well 4.5
to 5.5 bringing it up to 6.4
um so yeah and then organic matter
trying to get the organic matter up and
kind of interesting because
recently we did a whole bunch of soil
samples for the papaya guys
and a lot of them were up at five and i
was really surprised i didn't expect
that
um so yeah i land you some the land
is really expensive um you know you have
this pressure to develop
everybody wants some home in hawaii and
it's gotten really crazy
you know with covet because now you can
work wherever you want
and a lot of people want to move to
hawaii so the land prices are just
skyrocketing
you can buy a house for a million
dollars um you can buy a farm
you can buy a one acre a lot for a
million dollars
so the pressure uh is is really
creating a problem in hawaii i mean even
farmers with land today
they're getting surrounded by expensive
houses and now
those individuals are grumbling why are
you starting your tractor at five
o'clock in the morning
and what is that dust and what is that
noise and it's just
creating havoc for farming in hawaii um
and so there's a lot of backlash right
now people are saying we need to farm we
need
food security we produce um
15 of our food we depend on this
um bart system to bring food in we're
running into shortages right now
i went to the store last week the day
after the produce came in and
most of the produce was gone so
we're running into major problems right
now uh
with the food system um nationwide
and it seems like a lot of these big
corporations are trying to make their
money back
so the prices are going up real fast um
and it's creating a problem and not only
that buying up some of the small places
and
losing a lot of the mo and paul um
stores and stuff around
okay i see uh thomas bjorkman has a
a question and he's appeared so i think
he probably wants to ask it
sure okay thanks
yeah so a lot of a lot of what you're
describing is
has been happening in the peri urban
areas of new york as well so
yes people moving out and the land
prices going up and trying to make money
off of that
uh so i i'm actually curious about one
of the
trade-offs that they seem to handle well
so on the one hand
you have a desire for self-sufficiency
and cultural reinforcement and then on
the other hand
for the last 150 years or so the worst
job in the world the one
nobody wants is subsistence farmer
people have really voted with their feet
on that one so you don't want to be
training people to be
subsistence farmers who are unhappy and
wish they were doing anything else
how did you handle that trade-off well
see
on hawaiian homelands subsistence is
important
yeah and if you know how to do it you
can create a lot of production out of
subsistence
uh you have um agroforestry type systems
you got permaculture systems
um in hawaii i've seen some two acre
gardens that are just super productive
uh so for some people they can kind of
move from subsistence
into production small-scale production
the ones to me that have really excelled
are the ones where one partner is
working
and getting the medical and everything
and the other one is farming
that seems to be um you know um multiple
income the myths that seems to be the
one working a lot
um there's a new food system being
developed
in hawaii by farmers uh food hubs
this kind of thing getting the food
directly to the people
but what's interesting right now is that
since covet is going
open opening back up people are going
back to their own ways
they're going back to the big boxes
they're going back and they're not
buying from the farmers like they did
before
so that's a real that's a real problem
because i think the farmers had a real
opportunity
they had to really ramp up to cover the
needs
and now they gotta ramp down because
everybody's going back to their cmo cmo
ways
so i i don't know what the what the
answer is i mean i think
what i see happening then on our island
we have a mobile market
so um sunday afternoon you tell them
what you got
portions you know you got bags of
tomatoes whatever you tell them okay i
got
i got 25 half pound bags of tomatoes and
this all goes onto the internet
and monday morning it gets posted and
everybody on the island
orders and they are truly got a printout
and the prices are really high i mean i
can sell my tomatoes for seven
seven fifty a pound i was saying green
onions have this
hawaiian green onion that was actually
going for twenty dollars a pound
um but a lot of them are the snowbirds
they come over in the wintertime right
but a lot of the snowbirds didn't come
this year but they got stuck at home
so but but how do you feel how do you
feed the masses
is the is the million dollar question i
think and we're still trying to figure
that one out
right right the commodity stuff can come
in
i mean the the difference in shipping
from
rochester to new york or guanajuato to
new york yeah it's
it's not that different so you have a
little more isolation
you know i mean it's the system is
interesting because we had two big
hurricanes on kauai hurricane ira and
turkey and unique and i think after the
first hurricane
the state did this study to look at how
much food was in hawaii
and at that time they estimated about 21
days worth of food
because they had all this storage
capacity warehouses and stuff like that
since then the big boxes came to town
and there's no storage capacity and all
the storage
is on these container ships between
california
and hawaii so now we have seven days
worth of food
which is really scary um
and so if you're not farming i mean you
better be doing something
we have a real strong subsistence ethic
on this island
hunting and fishing we got a lot of fish
one of the only islands with a whole lot
of fish
we have deer coming out of our ears
right now getting tired of eating deer
although i might have some deer burgers
for dinner tonight
um so i don't know did i answer that
question i think
oh great okay great a lot of insight
okay enough and uh underhill uh
you go back in order uh uh wonders a
little bit about
uh could you do you think you could
replicate what you're doing without
such an interconnected culture
um it all comes down to trust
okay you know i i used to think that
land grant was the best thing
since motherhood and apple pie
until i understood what land grant
really meant
and it was pushing the natives out and
taking over their land
and genocide and removal the
national removal act of moving them out
of new york and taking them to oklahoma
and every place else so you have this
hurt
that's really hard to overcome and i
think it'll really differ between
one native group and another and how
open they are
some of them are it's more than
it's more than teaching it's about
healing about getting them
to understand um the modern system
some of them will not buy into the
modern system they won't buy into
capitalism
so you only can take them
from where they are to where they want
to be
so it really depends on that did i did i
unders did i explain that one
yeah absolutely thank you okay
uh thanks man uh i think marley
uh is next seriously hi i really enjoyed
your seminar
talk i was wondering i know you talked
about some of the crops that farmers
were growing interested in but were
there any that were
particularly culturally important and if
any of those were needing like breeding
efforts
uh especially like different light
squash or gourds
um probably the most important one is
taro
uh what's interesting about the
hawaiians is that they had at least
four staples when they came from i guess
taiwan
to polynesia um
six thousand years ago there were the
oka the new kids on the grou
uh the block there were people in the
pacific already the melanesians
um from new guinea actually coming down
the land bridge through um
indonesia to new guinea down to the um
gilbert islands and down to australia so
those guys were around probably 20 000
maybe even longer um so when the
when the polynesians they were called
austronesians and they came into
the pacific what allowed them to come
into the pacific was an innovation
called the double haul canoe prior to
that they all had single hou canoes that
would flip over in the waves
so they came in with the double canoe
and they knew they were gonna have a
hard time
so they actually brought along the way
four different staples
so these four staples are on taro sweet
potato
bread fruit and cooking bananas and
probably the most important ones
were on tarot number one and sweet
potato number two
so taro could grow in the wetter areas
the river valleys
sweet potato would grow in some of the
really dry areas
um we've done some work on sweet potato
trying to identify
new varieties but there's a strong
movement towards
um back to the ancient varieties um
in fact um the university of hawaii
tried to do some
genetic modification well they were
trying to patent tarot
they were crossing some tara from the
south pacific with the hawaii tarot to
develop um
phytophthora leaf blight resistance and
there was a huge backlash
um so i think you know you have that
side of it where they still want their
ancient foods
and they don't want it genetically
modified
so you can do um conventional breeding
we've done
some of that stuff um but it has to
taste
as good as the other stuff and
so far it hasn't so you're gonna
build up and you're going to pick up
resistance to something but the taste is
not going to be there
although um and the what's important
about
taro is um they used to dry it
and then when it when they needed to um
use it they could add water and it would
ferment
and it would last a long time but this
fermentation
um helped to digest all the other foods
they ate
so they would get total i guess total
use of all the food they ate and
today we deal a lot with diabetes and
stuff like that it was real interesting
i saw this article recently
um talking about um
the genetics of polynesians and they are
very
thrifty genetics so they didn't need to
eat a lot of food
so today you have the starches you have
the western foods
and they cannot handle you know they're
doing really bad in this regard
so this idea of going back to um native
foods is really important and
i've been rick working uh with
washington in the last
three weeks on trying to push our
indigenous foods initiative
um what what you need to push is
something that every state can
support you can't push this pork barrel
stuff for your state
and this is something that we could push
for a lot of states
a lot of states could buy into this
indigenous foods so
this has a lot of pieces to the puzzle
you need the genetics
you need to continue having the old
varieties of squash and corn
and those kind of things then you need
to um
get them into production and then you
need to get their food
this food into their food system so
i'm working on a grant right now um with
one of our representatives
um i have a classmate that has worked in
washington
for 40 years so usually in touch with
him and throwing ideas out to him
and he usually sends me texts about his
garden how if i can help him with his
garden
so i was on text with him on saturday
for an hour
um so i think that's one area you can do
improvement but it's got to be
acceptable by then
um thanks thank you glenn i think we are
unfortunately about out of time uh you
you
are doing so many things
uh thank you for coming and sharing uh
some of them with us
um and i hope to to get you back uh
to talk seeds at some point uh and so
looking forward to more uh connections
with you especially since you'll be
coming to uh new york now and then oh
yes i will and i gotta connect with you
i know you
you um told me hey you know stop by and
so i wanna i wanna
get that together soon let's do it well
thank you so much for a great talk glenn
it was uh it was fantastic and i look
forward to more chances to connect
okay michael take care bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu